Hey wisecrack, Jared here. If your bunker has reliable wifi,
you may have noticed a certain word making the rounds lately and a growing
Corona.
As far as crisis virus crisis to the COVID-19 crisis coronavirus crisis,
the Corona virus crisis, the Corona crisis.
COVID-19 is a crisis, but what exactly is a crisis,
the meaning of the word seems obvious enough, but as we're about to find out,
there's actually a lot more to it than you might think.
Philosophers from Lao-Tzu to Voltaire have been grappling with the idea of
crisis for millennia. And now we're going to throw our mask in the ring. I mean,
not literally, I've lost my spare.
Welcome as wisecrack edition on the philosophy of crisis in everyday speech
crisis is sometimes lumped in with words like disaster, catastrophe, et cetera.
That is words that call to mind some big,
terrible event that causes a lot of damage.
But the technical definition of the term is much more specific.
The English word crisis has its root in the Greek word Canadian,
which means to separate four, choose ancient Greek positions.
Use the term to refer to a precise moment in the development of an illness.
When a doctor must apply a particular treatment,
according to the Hippocratic medical tradition,
failing to act decisively during this brief window of opportunity could lead to
the death of the patient for Aristotle,
the root Canadian referred to a decision made in the political sphere.
That is a choice between contradictory options with the potential to create
lasting changes in society.
A crisis is a decisive moment in which there is the possibility for great harm
and great change.
And after which things can no longer be the same one historical crisis in
particular demonstrates how a devastating event can become the catalyst for
government overhaul, redistribution of power among institutions,
and even changes in religious thought.
I'm talking of course about the Lisbon earthquake of 1755.
Okay. So unless you're a history buff, you may not have heard of that one,
but this natural disaster and the way that individuals and institutions
responded to it contributed to major changes in the way that Europeans related
to their governments and had a big influence on some of the key thinkers behind
the scientific revolution on November. First of that year,
while many word church celebrating all saints day,
a massive earthquake struck the capital of Portugal,
the seismic activity leveled, many of the city's buildings,
crushing the people inside and as icing on the cake triggered a big old tsunami
that added to the destruction in the chaos that followed a massive fire,
broke out and burned away, much of what remained. It killed 60,000 people.
According to some estimates, the disaster sparked a crisis of authority,
specifically the authority of the church versus the authority of the state.
While the marquee of Palm ball defacto ruler of Portugal wanted Lisbon Knights
to focus on distributing food efficiently and rebuilding the city,
prominent Jesuit priest, Gabriel Malik,
Greta urged people to spend their time repenting for the sins that he felt had
brought God's judgment upon the city. Thankfully,
that kind of thing doesn't happen anymore. Us Senator called me and asked.
Me if hurricane Katrina was judgment from God. I said, yes.
Crisis forced a choice between the authority of the church and that of the
state, specifically a new absolutest former,
but the authority which would place ultimate decision-making power in the hands
of a sovereign at the center of a more secular government by ignoring the
church's plan for disaster response Pombal his actions would represent a huge
departure from centuries of church involvement in state affairs,
as seen in the coronation of Charlemagne by Pope Leo, the third,
all the way back in 800 CE in the end,
Pombo made the choice for Lisbon by having Malik Greta publicly humiliated,
strangled to death, and his body burned at the stake.
Like all crises Lisbon was at a critical juncture in the Greek sense was the
city to respond to the disaster with thoughts and prayers or, you know,
by digging survivors out from the rebel.
But it also became a critical juncture in philosophy in the wider European
world.
That catastrophe also led to a crisis of faith and philosophy that helped spawn
completely new ways of thinking about the world and its relation to the divine
before tectonic plates decided to treat Lisbon like an Etch-a-Sketch early
enlightenment intellectual spent a lot of time exploring theodicy.
The Odyssey is a branch of philosophy focused on reconciling the problem of evil
with the existence of a loving omnipotent God philosophers like Godfrey Leipnetz
argued that we live in the best of all possible worlds,
a universe in which evils like natural disaster and Wharf ultimately serve an
inherent good divine purpose,
which is beyond our mortal understanding for at least a few decades.
This very nice idea was reasonably persuasive to his fellow thinkers until
Lisbon in coming to grips with the disaster, French philosopher,
Voltaire Zoomer to live niches boomer came to believe that the idea of an
inherently good world was horrible against contemporary days.
Philosophers like John Jacques Rousseau,
who defended the notion of an essentially good universe ruled by some benevolent
force. Voltaire argued that our cosmos is fundamentally a moral, neither good,
nor bad in the wake of the Lisbon earthquake Voltaire wrote and published
candied and entire effing novella whose primary purpose is to roast live knits
and his metaphysical optimism. The story follows candied,
a young man who learns like Neetsy and philosophy from one professor Pangloss
full Tara portrays Pangloss as a buffoon whose dedication to optimism leads him
to absurd divine justifications for minor trivia and major evils alike.
Voltaire has this live net standard and say for instance,
that we all have noses because God was thoughtful enough to give us a place for
our spectacles and that it's ultimately all right,
that Columbus brought syphilis back from the new world because Hey,
at least Europe got chocolate out of it. And you thought your tweets were petty.
The crisis of Lisbon pushed European thought to its limits,
exposing the cracks in not only church authority,
but also the realm of philosophy in the decades. Following the crisis,
the philosophical community opted for a more secular paradigm.
Leaving questions about God, the theology,
and contributing to the of theological questions from philosophy at the same
time responsibility for understanding disasters shifted over to the emerging
field of science intellectuals.
Let off trying to figure out why bad things occur and started investigating how
they happen. Of course,
other crises perform similar roles in the aftermath of the Holocaust.
Philosophers were racked with basic questions of how did so-called civilization
birth. This monstrosity,
even the rise of fascism has been attributed to a series of crises,
which at critical junctures went the wrong way.
The arguments of thinkers like Italian philosopher,
Antonio Gramsci suggests that the conflicts exposed by long-term social change
enabled totalitarian movements to seek out even more or repressive means of
control. And for Carl Marx,
the whole theory that the world will move to communism is predicated on the idea
that capitalism generates economic crises and people will respond to those
crises by mass revolt.
Now whether it's an earthquake and economic collapse or a destructive political
movement, the point is a crisis tugs at the very structure of our world.
It exposes the cracks and weaknesses.
Economic crises can point to shortcomings in economic infrastructure,
natural disasters bring to light rampant inequality ranging from unsafe housing
to food insecurity, like the torch happy Pombo.
We are also facing a crisis which will force some pretty big decisions over the
next few years COVID-19 and our response to it.
We'll be sure to highlight a store of problems embedded in society.
Take for instance, how different countries responded to the pandemic,
which revealed very strength or weakness of that different system of government.
While some have noted that China's authoritarian government was able to
successfully STEM the spread of the virus.
The flip side is that the same government's lack of transparency allowed the
infection to spread and secrecy in its early stages. On the other hand,
democracies have greater transparency as well as a free press.
That's able to share information and criticize or support official policy,
but those same democracies may be hesitant to enforce lockdown with heavy handed
policing and stricter rules, but pushing the limits of the democratic process.
Isn't the only problem this crisis is exposing.
It's also exposing issues in an area that may seem totally unrelated,
industrial meat production on the human front.
The fast paced production lines of the meat industry has workers laboring closer
to each other than ever.
And so it's no surprise that Tyson reported nearly 900 cases of COVID at one
plant alone, but to zoom out a little COVID exposures,
just how vulnerable we are to diseases that find a welcome breeding ground in
factory farms, evolutionary biologists,
Rob Wallace has pointed out that modern animal feedlots,
which pack thousands of animals together in close quarters are the little bears
bed to the flu viruses, Goldilocks,
a cozy biological stew in which to fester and mutate both the
2009 H one N one virus and the 1918 Spanish flu. Yeah,
that flu have been traced back to American feedlots.
Now we're not trying to take away anyone's hamburgers.
And if anyone tries to take ours,
we've collectively sworn to cut it still with the U S meat dwindling as factory
farms and processing plants fall to COVID outbreaks.
It might be worth exploring whether we absolutely have to get our stake import
chops by cramming thousands of animals together in monotonous,
unsanitary conditions for the duration of their short lives or whether there
might be a better way.
Another weakness that COVID and similar diseases expose is how structural
inequalities of all kinds can help create pockets of highly vulnerable people
within the broader population of a city nation, et cetera,
with diminished access, to testing and treatment, these groups,
indoor disproportionate pain and debt,
and can become the unwilling vectors for the spread of disease to other parts of
the population.
The virus has thrown these effects into sharp relief and in the process brought
up questions about how we ought to structure our economies, governments,
and societies,
and who ought to control them and how everybody has something to say about
everyone. Else's response to the pandemic,
whether they're shaking a fist at Florida beach goers,
or seriously considering the upside of centralized despotism people everywhere
are thinking hard about where power belongs,
even in the U S federal interventions that would have sounded crazy just a few
months ago are already up and running $2 trillion stimulus package,
anyone check place while no one knows for sure what our world will look like on
the other side of this particular crisis.
One thing is certain things will never be quite the same,
but what do you think wisecrack?
What are some of the biggest decisions we face as a result of the COVID-19
crisis? What might change over the next few years?
Let us know what you think in the comments below big,
thanks to all our patrons and be sure to subscribe and ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].